me piden que encuentre la suma de tres
enteros un octavo más tres cuartos más
ya que tengo una cantidad negativa más
menos dos enteros un sexto y que
encontré la suma de justo esto y tenemos
un problema de fracciones así que qué te
parece si para empezar visualizamos esto
en la recta numérica si aquí tengo una
recta numérica ok
entonces voy a hacer esta recta numérica
y primero vamos a fijarnos en estas dos
cantidades positivas que sabemos operar
bastante bien porque es lo que hemos
visto en los últimos vídeos así que
imagínate que por aquí tengo al cero por
aquí tengo el cero por aquí tengo al 1
por aquí tengo el 1 por acá tengo el 2
ok por acá tengo el 3 ok y si quiero
representar tres enteros no octavo si
por acá tengo el 4 ok
tres enteros un octavo se vería más o
menos así sería empezar aquí en cero
ok irme hasta dónde está el 3
y pasar un octavo más después del 3 algo
más o menos como por aquí llegaríamos a
algo más o menos como por aquí y después
de regreso ok de regreso aquí estoy
representando tres entre los octavos así
que déjame colorear todo esto déjame
colorear todo esto ok
más o menos así déjame colorear todo
esto ok para que aquí tengamos a tres
enteros un octavo de lujo ok
todo esto es tres centros un octavo y
déjame poner que estos son tres enteros
un octavo bien por cierto esto lo
podemos ver como una fracción impropia
de la siguiente manera multiplicamos 8
por 3 8 por 3 es 24 24 más unos 25 25
octavos 25 octavos es lo mismo que tres
enteros un octavo ok y ahora si nos
fijamos en la suma de las dos cantidades
positivas de estas dos fracciones
positivas que por cierto es lo que ya
sabemos nosotros hemos repasado bastante
bien esto imagínate que aquí tengo a
tres enteros un octavo ya esto le voy a
sumar es decir
empezar justo aquí y le voy a sumar tres
cuartos y llegaría a algo más o menos
como por acá
imagínate que por acá tenemos a tres
cuartos ok entonces déjame colorear esto
y aquí tengo tres cuartos y bueno antes
de meterme en el problema con esta
cantidad negativa que te parece si de
una vez realizamos la operación de 25
octavos que bueno sabemos que es tres
enteros un octavo más tres cuartos ya
que vamos a llegar vamos a ponerlo con
color verde y me quedaría 25
le voy a poner aquí 25 octavos más tres
cuartos y bueno necesitamos un
denominador común por lo tanto el
denominador común es 8 y voy a escribir
todo en términos de 8 8 entre 8 es 1
aquí no hay nada que hacer y entonces
aquí arriba me queda 25 ya esto le voy a
sumar tres cuartos pero déjame ponerlo
con otro color tres cuartos cuando yo lo
paso en un denominador común que es el 8
estoy multiplicando al 4
4 x 2008 por lo tanto la parte de arriba
también tengo que multiplicarla por 2
para que se conserve esta fracción y
entonces 3 por 2 mil 625 6 entre 8 que
por cierto esto va a ser igual y déjame
cambiar otra vez el color verde esto
mismo que 25 + 6 es 31 31 sobre 8 es
decir que si nosotros empezamos justo
aquí y paramos justo acá empezamos justo
aquí y paramos justo acá en total hay 31
octavos y déjame ponerlo justo aquí yo
voy a empezar por aquí voy a seguir voy
a seguir voy a seguir hasta acá justo en
este punto
ok paro ya que llegó hasta 31 octavos
que es te das cuenta 31 octavos es un
poco menos que 4 hoy ya me fue un poco
choco es un poco menos que 4
estamos justo antes que el 4 así que
vamos bien déjame colorear toda esta
flecha de clip para que se vea que tiene
un poco de volumen y no se vea tanto que
me equivoqué muy feo por aquí ok de lujo
entonces toda esta fecha representa 25
octavos
tres cuartos que quedamos que es lo
mismo que 31 octavos 31 octavos ok la
suma de estos dos ahora aquí tengo que
sumarle y vamos a cambiar de color
tengo que sumarle una cantidad negativa
a esto le voy a sumar menos dos enteros
un sexto que representa esto bueno
cuando yo sumo una cantidad negativa lo
que representa es justo lo contrario en
lugar de seguir hacia la derecha voy a
regresar me voy a empezar justo aquí ya
esta cantidad de 31 sobre 8 le voy a
poner una flecha que retroceda una ok
2 ok 2 un sexto dos enteros
un sexto esta fecha representa dos
enteros un sexto pero en lugar de ir
esta vez hacia la derecha voy a hacer la
izquierda voy en sentido contrario lo
que quiere decir es que cuando yo estoy
sumando una cantidad negativa realmente
lo que voy a hacer es restar restar a 31
octavos dos enteros un sexto y bueno
vamos a poner que esto representa menos
dos enteros
un sexto ir hacia el otro lado
representa dos enteros un sexto y
entonces mi resultado va a quedar justo
esta parte de aquí mi resultado va a
quedar algo positivo y va a ser
equivalente a esta fecha que tengo aquí
va a ser la resta de 31 octavos o espera
no parece flecha la resta de 31 octavos
menos dos enteros un sexto y esa va a
ser mi respuesta que por cierto es una
cantidad positiva por lo tanto no
tenemos que hablar del valor absoluto y
vamos a
justo cuánto es lo que representa lo que
tengo aquí y para esto lo que tengo que
hacer es tomarme la diferencia de esta
cantidad lo voy a poner aquí 31 octavos
ya esto le voy a quitar con color
naranja le voy a quitar 2 enteros o un
sexto que es lo mismo que menos
6 por 2 12 más 1 13 13 sextos estoy
pasando desde un número mixto a una
fracción de impropia 13 sextos ok ahora
si nos queremos tomar esta diferencia
que tengo aquí lo único que hay que
hacer es buscar un denominador común y
bueno si buscamos un denominador común
te vas a dar cuenta que el mínimo común
múltiplo entre estos dos es 24 24 así
que vamos a escribir todo en términos de
24 si te das cuenta pase de 8 de 8 a 24
lo que quiere decir que multiplique el
denominador por 3 3 por 8 24 y entonces
la parte de arriba la tengo que
multiplicar también por 3 para llegar a
esta cantidad que va a ir justo aquí voy
a multiplicar por 3
por tres y me quedan tres por una 3
ok 3 por 3 3 993 a 93 le voy a quitar y
ahora date cuenta que estamos aquí este
6 lo multiplique por cuatro para llegar
a ser este 24 6 por 4 es 24 y entonces
la parte de arriba también la tengo que
multiplicar por 4 para obtener este
número que va justo aquí hay que
multiplicar la parte de arriba por 4 y
me queda que 4 por 3 es 12 llevamos 14
por 14 y unam 5 52 por lo tanto mi
resultado va a ser igual mi resultado va
a ser igual o no ya no me cabe lo voy a
poner justo aquí mi resultado va a ser
igual a 93 menos 52 lo cual es a 1 4141
sobre 24 ya escrito con mi nuevo
denominador común denominador común eso
quiere decir que esta fecha de aquí
representa 41 entre 24 41 entre 24 es
justo lo que vale esta fecha aquí y si
te das cuenta 41 entre 24 es un poco
más pequeño que 224 por 2 348 y si te
das cuenta estamos pues sigue un poquito
antes que 2 estamos justo como por aquí
y por lo tanto estamos bien lo primero
que hice fue tomarme la suma de las dos
fracciones positivas lo cual sabíamos
hacer muy bien y después me doy cuenta
que cuando tengo la suma de una fracción
negativa realmente lo que voy a hacer es
retroceder voy a retroceder o en su dado
caso voy a restar la cantidad que me
dice justo aquí y con esto llegamos el
resultado